and so that was the beginning of the end
for my parents relationship and I'm
sharing all this stuff and I'm becoming
vulnerable
and you're just working out
love is blind and jumping jacks aren't
quite as you think we've come a long way
since then right now on Netflix we've
got new episodes so my buddy nickel Shea
is here to chat all about it okay who
has been your favorite couple so far to
watch this season oh to watch yeah I
mean xenob and Cole that's good TV
there's a lot to absorb there so we
should just swap beyonces great
what couple has surprised you guys the
most this season Raven and that's okay
that was three episodes dropped today we
see one of the couples as you mentioned
SK Raven at the altar what can you tease
I the altar ceremonies are high high
drama let me just put it this way there
are things that happen in season three
at the altar that we've never seen
happen in previous Seasons so all I can
say really get ready for it it's uh it
gets interesting is your head and your
heart in the same spot I don't know
that's why I think reality TV works so
well yeah it's you can't script this
stuff like you don't know how it's going
to play out Vanessa and I have no idea
how it's going to play if you guys are
home on your couches arguing with your
significant other about the show know
that Vanessa and I are doing the exact
same thing is love truly blind
we obviously hope that you prove it is
you know when you have a successful show
you do start to open yourselves up for
criticism and we just recently heard
um Alum season one Lauren speed Hamilton
she shared some thoughts about the show
and she said that I don't like how love
is blind be cutting all the black women
how come they're always in the trailer
but not in the show what do you think
about her observation I mean it's a fair
observation but I guess the counter
argument to that is that it's not
manipulated in the sense that the people
gravitate who they to who they gravitate
to right I think that all you can do in
terms of being a show and being a
casting department is is casted
um you know uh fairly and cast it with
with great diversity and I think that
they've done a good job of trying to you
know to do that yeah okay I have to ask
you after three seasons now do you
believe that love is actually blind
uh I believe that it it can be so is it
is it enough no physical certainly plays
a part at some point but I do think they
had emotional connection
um can be a great foundation for the
rest of it maybe we call it love love
needs LASIK surgery
maybe not blind but just got eye
problems I love that for you for me or
for us
um all right before we let you go gotta
ask you about Halloween
um you had the fam dress up as NCIS yeah
to honor mom yeah okay when is the 98
Degrees costumes gonna come you know
what Kevin thank you I'm just saying
I've said this before my kids could care
less if I'm 98 Degrees I'm like this is
a huge chapter I'll get my time my
time's coming okay listen we're actually
gonna check in with your wifey because
she's working over in the mainland right
now what's up Vanessa hey babe hi guys
babe make sure you tell the kids mommy
will be home in two sleeps of course
last night Mama wasn't sleeping her
reaction to love is blind wedding
bombshell at first I was like oh I don't
know about this couple and then by the
wedding day I was hyperventilating
crying
and it really just it hit my heart all
right so let's explain why Vanessa's
away from the fam she's in La shooting
ncis's big three-show crossover that's
why Nick is on Daddy Duty uh he's at
home hard at work have you ever had
three kids by yourself he's doing the
hard job I get to play out here with all
these NCIS Legends so Nick has the hard
job I think right now this is a break I
had a five and a half hour flight with
no kids and no husband I got a nap in
yesterday
yeah but don't tell him that your
secret's safe with us but Vanessa did
have a message for her hubby of 11 years
babe I won't see you we're literally
going to be Crossing flights because
he's gonna go to uh college football
this weekend so I love you and I'll see
you next week but you better be home for
our birthday November 9th we decided
never to do presents after our first
birthday so we usually go on a trip so
um
where are we going
I actually have to get time off of work
so I should probably talk to CBS
[Music]
and thank you to our Ohana nicochet
my pleasure by this time if we're not
family then I don't know what you guys
come to my hood I got to come down and
hang out there absolutely now season
three of Love is Blind is on Netflix
right now and you may need a little of
this to get you through the series
seriously a lot of it a lot of it we're
gonna try out some kohana rum we've got
Kyle Rooter from The Distillery and
Michael souderman from the Sheraton
Waikiki Royal Hawaiian singer nice tone
now listen I do like a little rum so
tell us about it we grow all the sugar
cane ourselves and then we use the fresh
juice instead of molasses wow are we
just gonna taste pour that lightly
because Tipsy Turner will show up
quickly that's really nice and can we
point out the uh the Love is Blind
goblets too nice
[Music]
that's wrong
how was that but that is so good well so
this is our Coco lecca kokoleka means
chocolate in Hawaiian
wasn't there something in your courting
history about a martini or a chocolate
martini Vanessa's she's an equal
opportunity Martini drinker
what do you put in front of her listen
cheers guys cheers cheers and um hey
cheers appreciate it guys take care
everybody and we'll see you right back
here tomorrow
foreign